- The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Let's do
a little general discussion
of some of the political
issues that we will encounter.
This is a-- if you read
why there are governments,
if you read what governments say
about why they are established,
you get very
high-flown language.
This is The Declaration of
Independence, life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
Governments are to
assure those rights.
This is The Constitution,
a little less high-flying--
establish justice, ensure
domestic tranquility,
provide for the common defense,
promote the general welfare,
and secure the
blessings of liberty.
You will notice that we
have domestic tranquility,
common defense, things
that are a little less
high-flowing than life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
Does anybody know
where this comes from?
This is the law
that it's actually
an act the English
government that sets up
Canada as a separate state.
Peace, order, and good
government-- somewhat different
emphasis than life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
If you look at--
lots of other governments
don't write down--
or lots of other countries, lots
of regimes, postrevolutionary,
Henry VIII, Ivan the Terrible,
Khmer Rouge, Joseph Stalin,
Adolf Hitler would not
write statements like that.
But they had goals.
They have goals.
A key element of a
functioning government
is a near monopoly
on the use of force.
If you think about it, when
you think about Somalia
is a failed state, or
Libya is a failing state
not that long ago.
What broke was the monopoly
on the use of deadly force--
near monopoly-- near monopoly.
Is Syria a failed state yet?
Probably not.
Is it en route?
Maybe.
But that's-- every government
that's really a government--
really a government-- has a
monopoly on the use of force.
It also has-- governments
tend to have legitimacy.
That is to say,
even in North Korea,
people aren't followed
around by a man with a gun.
People follow orders without
the use of force, generally--
generally.
Legitimacy can come from
a number of sources.
Again, if you think
about it in the abstract,
the US government probably gets
its legitimacy from the fact
that most people think
the processes followed
are reasonably fair.
You might not have
liked the decision
in Bush versus Gore that
gave the election to Bush,
but it followed
a certain process
and, yeah, you didn't like it,
but fundamentally, the process
was OK.
You don't like the Bills that
come out of Congress, but you
know how people are elected--
blah, blah, blah.
In the days of the
divine right of kings,
legitimacy came
from someplace else.
Legitimacy came from the fact
that that king was the king.
And God said, he's the king.
Do what he says.
That's a pretty good
source of legitimacy.
Or you could have
a government that's
arbitrary, doesn't
have divine rights,
but is doing things
that people like.
You might ask, why was
the Hitler government--
why did it have
legitimacy in Germany?
Because the variety
of the goals it
was pursuing were popular goals.
Was the process that
put it in office fair?
Not really.
Was Adolf Hitler
divinely endorsed?
Not really.
But restoring
German self-respect,
expanding the territory
of the country,
making it a power again,
et cetera, et cetera,
those were popular goals.
And sometimes-- North Korea--
you have legitimacy
because the consequences
of not following orders
are pretty terrible.
So you follow orders.
Governments also have
policies and a process
for changing them.
I want to spend just
a couple of minutes
about how the market system--
the market, which you
all studied in economics,
differs from the political
world, which we will
be spending some time on here.
In the market, we think
of individuals or firms
pursuing self-interest.
That happens in the
political world.
But what also happens in
the political world is, A,
groups are involved,
not just individuals--
parties, interest groups,
trade associations,
industries acting together.
And you see the pursuit
both of self-interest
and have different views
of the public interest.
Because in the market--
right-- you make
decisions for yourself,
firm makes decisions for itself.
In the political
world most decisions
are for the community.
So the question is not
only what's good for me--
that matters, obviously--
but what's good
for the community.
How do I think a
government should work?
community, a state,
a country should be organized?
What goals should it pursue?
That gets us to the
question of ideology.
In the market,
individual decisions
are driven by
individual preferences.
In the political world,
ideology matters.
Different views of how
the state should operate,
how society should
work, and what
arrangements should be adopted.
So you and I might,
for instance,
agree that society should
take care of poor people--
or that poor people
should be taken care of.
People on the market
side might say, yeah,
that's what families are for.
That's how the state should be
organized to achieve that goal,
is families should understand
that that's their duty to take
care of poor relatives
and poor friends.
People on the state
side might, say, well,
that's all well and good,
but that won't work.
That won't work.
You might have different
goals, of course.
People on the market
side might say,
the notion that the poor should
be taken care of is a bad idea.
It'll rob them of incentives.
And if the poor don't
have incentives,
they'll be a burden
on the rest of us,
and we just shouldn't have that.
People on the state side
might say, no, no, no.
You've got to take care of the
poor, it's simple humanity.
Forget all the incentives.
Those are ideological
statements.
Those are statements about
how the government, how
the society, how the community,
what should it work to do?
And how best to get there?
They don't arise--
those kinds of issues
don't arise in
the market, right?
Market economy, you're
buying, you're selling,
you're pursuing your interest,
you're maximizing profit.
None of this stuff comes--
it may come up, but
it's not central.
It's not central.
In the political
system, it's central.
So if I can do this--
let me just for fun--
if I've still got it.
No, I don't still have it--
wait a sec.
Yeah, I do.
Just for humor.
Let's do Howard Roark.
This is a statement of ideology.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I shall call no witnesses.
This will be my testimony
and my summation.
- Take the oath.
- Do you swear to tell the
truth, the whole truth,
and nothing but the
truth, so help you God?
- I do.
- Thousands of years
ago, the first man
discovered how to make fire.
He was probably
burned at the stake
he taught his brothers to
light, but he left them
a gift they had not conceived.
And he lit the
darkness off the Earth.
Throughout the
centuries, there were
men who took first steps down
new roads armed with nothing
but their own vision.
The great creators.
The thinkers, the artists,
the scientists, the inventors
stood alone against
the men of their time.
Every new thought was opposed.
Every new invention
was denounced.
But the men of unborrowed
vision went ahead.
They fought, they suffered,
and they paid, but they won.
No creator was prompted by a
desire to please his brothers.
His brothers hated
the gift he offered.
His truth was his only motive.
His work was his only goal.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: This
is a model of progress.
Where does it come from?
- --his creation, not the
benefits others derived from
it.
The creation which
gave form to his truth.
He held his truth above all
things and against all men.
He went ahead whether others
agreed with him or not,
with his integrity
as his only banner.
He served nothing and no one.
He lived for himself.
And only by living
for himself was
he able to achieve the things
which are the glory of mankind.
Such is the nature
of achievement.
Man cannot survive
except through his mind.
He comes on Earth unarmed.
His brain is his only weapon.
But the mind is an
attribute of the individual.
There is no such thing
as a collective brain.
The man who thinks must
think and act on his own.
The reasoning mind cannot work
under any form of compulsion.
It cannot be subordinated
to the needs, opinions,
or wishes of others.
It is not an object
of sacrifice.
The creator stands
on his own judgment.
The parasite follows
the opinions of others.
The creator thinks.
The parasite copies.
The creator produces,
the parasite loots.
The creator is concern is
the conquest of nature.
The parasite's concerned
is the conquest of man.
The creator requires
independence--
he neither serves nor rules.
He deals with men by free
exchange and voluntary choice.
The parasite seeks power.
He wants to bind
all men together
in common action
and common slavery.
He claims--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: That's
what we call a government.
- --a tool for
the use of others.
That he must think as they
think, act that they act,
and live in selfless,
joyless servitude
to any need but his own.
Look at history.
Everything we have,
every great achievement
has come from the independent
work of some independent mind.
Every horror and destruction
came from attempts
to force men into a herd of
brainless, soulless robots
without personal rights,
without personal ambition,
without will, hope, or dignity.
It is an ancient conflict.
It has another name.
The individual against
the collective.
Our country, the noblest
country in the history of men,
was based on the principle
of individualism.
The principle of man's
inalienable rights.
It was a country where a man was
free to seek his own happiness,
to gain and produce, not
to give up and renounce;
to prosper, not to starve;
to achieve, not to plunder;
to hold as his highest position
a sense of his personal value,
and as his highest
virtue his self-respect.
Look at the results.
That is what the collectivists
are now asking you to destroy,
as much of the Earth
has been destroyed.
I am an architect.
I know what is to come by the
principle on which it is built.
We are approaching a world in
which I cannot permit myself
to live.
My ideas are my property.
They were taken from me by
force by breach of contract.
No appeal was left to me.
It was believed that my
work belonged to others
to do with as they pleased.
That they had a claim upon
me without my consent,
that it was my duty to serve
them without choice or reward.
Now you know why I
dynamited Courtland.
I designed Courtland.
I made it possible.
I destroyed it.
I agreed to design
it for the purpose
of seeing it built as I wished.
That was the price
that I set for my work.
I was not paid.
My building was
disfigured at the whim
of others who took all
the benefits of my work
and gave me nothing in return.
I came here to say that I do not
recognize anyone's right to one
minute of my life, nor
to any part of my energy,
nor to any achievement of mine,
no matter who makes the claim.
It had to be said.
The world is perishing from
an orgy of self-sacrificing.
I came here to be
heard in the name
of every man of independence
still left in the world.
I wanted to state my terms.
I do not care to work
or live on any others'.
My terms are a man's right
to exist for his own sake.
[END PLAYBACK]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So I'm not--
I'm not going to ask for a vote.
But you see that is an
ideological statement.
It is about how the
world must be organized--
should be organized--
to permit progress.
The inventors have
to be free to invent,
the parasites have
to be suppressed.
It's an ideological statement.
It's not just how
he wants to live,
but how others should live.
How the government, how the
society should be organized.
There's another example
on the list, which
was long, and
tedious, and optional,
so I assume nobody read it.
But I will give you the story.
It's kind of an amazing story.
It's a description of the
London electrical system--
the Hughes reading--
before the First World War.
Now by, say, 1914, there was
lots of electricity in Chicago.
Chicago was electrified.
There were trolleys.
There was a company
that spanned the city.
There was a lot of--
electricity had penetrated
a good deal in Berlin.
Again, a single system, modern
by the standards of the day.
In London, there were--
what's it say?
65 utilities operating on
10 different frequencies
with 24 different voltages
delivered to customers.
And it's not like London
was populated by idiots
or there weren't engineers.
There were plenty of engineers.
They had societies of
electrical engineers,
just like the Germans did
and the Americans did.
And commissions regularly
said, this is insane.
This is crazy.
Appliance makers
said, this is nuts.
We can't sell the
same appliances
in this part of London that we
sell in that part of London.
The US has a standard,
Germany has the standard,
London has 10 frequencies and
24 voltages and 65 companies.
So why?
Well, since nobody read it
but me, I'll tell you why.
Because London was divided
into a set of local governments
that had, since the Middle Ages,
authority over their domains.
And the ideology
was this is local.
It goes to residences.
It goes to factories.
It's the domain of
local government.
That was the ideology.
That's the statement about
how that society should
be organized.
Local government should--
no maximization here--
local government should have
control over local utilities.
It took them a long
time to get past that.
And you say, wait,
couldn't you just say
that that's all fine,
that's a nice ideology.
But why don't we just get
the electrical system right?
It was the biggest,
richest city in the world
and it had a terrible
electrical system
because of this ideology.
How could they possibly
have gone with it?
Well, you will see in the
course of human event,
as you read the
paper and as you read
other things, this kind of
thing happens all the time.
Beliefs about how things
should be organized, beliefs
about the right way for
a community to organize
are very strong.
They don't change rapidly.
We have a federal system.
I will discuss later on how
we regulate the electric power
system in this country.
And we do a lot of
pretending that electrons
don't cross state lines.
But of course they do.
But the ideology is
that's a state function.
And if you stand up and
say, why in heaven's name--
I mean, we do have
national standards.
It's not like London.
But if you stand
up and say, this
ought to be a federal
function, you'd get shot.
I mean, it's just
not on the table.
You can't have a
technical debate
about would it be good or
bad because of the strength
of the ideologies.
Now I don't say that as an
indictment of human society.
You have to have
beliefs about how
the world should be organized.
How do you function
without them?
Just like you have to have
preferences about do you
like tacos or burritos?
I mean, you have to
get through life.
You have to have views of how
the world should be organized
and how people--
how the government should
pursue certain goals.
Those beliefs might want
to occasionally brush up
against facts, just like your
preferences for ice cream
might occasionally want
to brush up against facts
about cholesterol.
But fundamentally, just like
you need preferences and habits
to get through the
day, individuals
in the political
world need ideologies.
So that's not a
pejorative statement.
The other point I want to make--
a difference between the
market and the polis,
the political world,
is we generally assume
in economics that individuals--
at some point in
time, at least--
have relatively
well-defined preferences.
Well-defined preferences
basically just
means you're consistent.
You don't behave in a
way that that's obviously
evidence of an unsound mind.
Political judgment can be
inconsistent in that sense.
Let me just give you
the simplest case
of the Condorcet paradox,
which a very bright Frenchman
discovered in 1785.
And it's a special case of
a general rule that says--
for which Ken Arrow
got a Nobel Prize--
and it says, basically, any
regime without a dictator
will behave inconsistently in
roughly the following sense.
Let me say I've got three
individuals, three voters.
This is what the
slide says, but I'm
going to unpack it a
little bit, 1, 2, and 3.
And there are three alternatives
A, B, and C. So individual 1
prefers A to B and prefers B
to C. Individual 2 prefers C--
that's her first choice--
C to A, and A to B. Individual
3 prefers B to C to A.
OK.
So suppose I have a
vote between A and B.
If I have a vote between
A and B, 1 prefers A to B,
2 prefers A to B. So if I
vote, A is preferred to B.
Now let me do B versus
C. 1 prefers B to C,
3 prefers B to C.
So the vote tells me
that B is preferred to C.
Now let me do A and C. 2 prefers
C to A, 3 prefers C to A. C
is preferred to A. That
is inconsistent behavior.
If an individual behaved
in that fashion, and said,
I prefer chocolate
to strawberry,
I prefer strawberry
to vanilla, but I
prefer vanilla to chocolate,
you'd say, I'm sorry,
wait a minute.
What?
But in voting, that can
happen all the time.
And it also says, for
instance, if you'd like to--
you'd really like to be the
chairman of this committee
because if you're the chairman
of this committee, whoever
you are, you can set the agenda
to get the outcome you want.
Suppose you're number 1.
You want A. So what do you do?
You first have a vote
between B and C. B wins.
Then you say, OK,
let's try A and B--
A wins.
Of course, if you're number
2, then what you'd like to do
is start with the A/B vote--
A wins.
And then do the A/C vote--
C wins.
The kind of consistency
that we expect
when we talk about
individual behavior
is not a necessary feature
of political behavior,
of collective behavior.
With a dictator, OK, sure.
With a voting system--
you name your system, it
is capable of that kind
of inconsistency,
even if it's not--
even if it's not voting.
So let me do just--
have a couple more remarks
before we get to the case.
In the market system, the
main process is competition.
There may be other things going
on, depending on the system.
Is competition perfect,
is it not perfect?
Is there monopoly?
But the central feature of a
market system is competition.
Competition happens in politics,
but it's not the only process.
Think about what we're
going through now
in the Republican
primary process.
There's a ton spent
trying to influence.
That happens in politics.
It happens through TV ads.
It also happens in
parliaments and legislatures
when people try to
persuade other people.
You try to persuade them to
act in ways that benefit you,
and you try to persuade
them that, in fact, it
benefits them to do so--
influence.
Cooperation-- again, what are
political parties all about?
They're a group of
people working together
for a common end,
typically, or a team,
or a set of folks in
a legislature trying
to get something done.
Groups act politically.
You listen to-- you
read descriptions
of Japanese politics, and
it's all about this faction
and that faction.
It's all about cooperating
groups in the same party
but pursuing different ends.
And loyalty-- changing your
position a lot in politics
costs your friends,
costs you influence.
So a lot of what happens is
Democrats hold their noses
and vote for a Democrat
they don't really
like because she's a Democrat.
Republicans do the same thing.
We'll see that in the fall.
I'm loyal, this
is what I believe.
It's not perfect,
I'm going there.
There's nothing like
that in the marketplace.
You may be loyal
to Chevrolet even
though it produces a lousy car,
but this is not a common event.
Loyalty in politics
is more important,
cooperation's more important,
and influence Yeah, there's
influence in the market--
of course, people advertise.
But influence is sort
of central to politics.
There's not much influence
in the wheat market.
But there's a lot
of influence in
the Republican primary market.
All right.
So when you think about--
there's competition--
people try to win,
people want to
advance, and so on.
But it's different.
Finally, when you
think about politics--
when you think about the market,
the goals you think about
are utility or wealth.
And I just said
wealth to save space,
but you think of folks
as self-interested
in a particularly narrow way.
In politics, of course,
people pursue wealth--
of course.
But they also pursue power
and power is different.
Power is sometimes-- sometimes
is conferred by an office.
You're president, the
system has legitimacy,
therefore you have power.
Power means you can
get others to act
against their self-interest.
You can get them to pay
taxes, for instance.
You can get them to put their
lives on the line in a war.
You have the ability to do a
variety of things against--
to get people to do
a variety of things
against their self-interest,
either for you or for your view
of the public interest.
So the important coin of the
realm in politics-- and again,
there's nothing quite like
it in the market system--
is power-- is power.
Power comes from influence,
cooperation, loyalty, sometimes
force, also comes
from the legitimacy
of the government you're in.
You hear occasionally
about people
in legislatures being
powerful not necessarily
because they have some office
that makes them powerful,
but because they've managed
to attract a set of followers
because they have some
ability to confer favors
because, because, because.
When I was in
Washington, John Dingell,
the Congressman from Michigan,
was legendarily powerful.
He was chairman of a committee.
He was a Congressman, he
was chairman of a committee.
The committee had a
lot of jurisdiction.
Dingell also had a
very smart staff.
Dingell also knew
everybody in town.
Dingell would send letters to
people in the executive branch
called Dingellgrams
that would consist
of four pages of detailed
questions written
by his staff that needed to
be answered within a week.
You get a letter from like
that from anybody else,
you'd say, yeah, right.
You got a letter like that
from Dingell, you answered it.
You put people on it
and you answered it
because Dingell had power--
Dingell had power.
Hard to exactly describe
why Dingell had power,
but Dingell had power.
He could move votes, he
could build coalitions,
he could operate.
He had power.
OK.
We now have our introduction
to political science
and political philosophy.
Let's do a little
bit of Carter Coal.
Some of the background-- which
we didn't quite give you,
but let me just do a little
bit of that to get to it.
This is the New Deal period,
and Roosevelt is doing--
has gotten a Democratic
Congress to pass
a variety of laws that extend
the power of government
in an attempt to use
in a variety of ways to
deal with the Depression.
Beginning in early
1935, the Supreme Court
was striking these down
regularly as unconstitutional.
There was a fairly long
list of things struck down.
They'd struck down an earlier
piece of legislation in the--
oh, I'm forgetting it now.
It's one the-- the Schechter
decision, Schechter Poultry,
struck down basically an
industry regulatory statute
that, like the coal statute,
the Bituminous Coal Conservation
Act, was an attempt to raise
prices and raise wages.
The theory was we have
ruinous competition, so we're
going to deal with
the Depression
by getting prices up,
which will get wages up,
which will get people
spending, which will get us out
of this mess.
Now it's not the best
economics, but that was
the deal he was trying to do.
And this act which just
focused on the coal industry,
attempted to raise
prices and wages,
and was drafted to
get around Schechter.
So they'd thrown out an earlier
law in the Schechter decision.
So somebody said, all right.
Let's write this so that under
the standards of Schechter,
its legal.
It involved getting people
to-- getting coal manufacturers
to obey the law by imposing
a tax on them, most of which
was refunded if they followed
the practices laid out
in the act.
It's Carter versus Carter Coal--
I love this.
This guy's board of directors
votes to pay the tax.
The CEO sues them.
This is an odd action.
The law says you
have to pay the tax.
The board says, yeah,
we'll pay the tax.
The CEO says, the hell we
will, and sues the board.
Okey-doke.
And as long as you
have recognized,
and as you've discussed last
week, this case on its face
is a technical exercise
in legal analysis.
This is how court decisions
are always written.
It's fascinating.
Judges never say, well,
there's this consideration
and there's this consideration.
And in the balance, I
think I should go this way.
They almost always say,
there's this consideration
and people have made this
argument, but it's junk,
so we should go this way.
And those tend to be--
reflect differences
in ideology, right?
It's clear that
Sutherland and Cardozo--
we'll talk briefly
about Hughes--
but Sutherland and Cardozo
have a different view
of how the United States
should be organized
and how the government
should be run.
So let's do this.
What are the two
provisions at issue here?
Anybody?
Brendan, you've
got a great sign.
Other people will have a great
sign, but I can read yours.
What are the two provisions
in the Bituminous Coal Act
that the court is dealing with?
AUDIENCE: First, like
the Commerce Clause.
Like whether the--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's the issue
in terms of constitutionality.
But what are two
things that the act
did that are challenged here?
AUDIENCE: First, can you just
set a manipulation for price,
like this is what
the price has to be.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It
set a price for coal.
OK.
Anything else?
Scott, what else did it do?
AUDIENCE: Put a tax on it.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Put a tax, yeah, yeah.
But that was an
enforcement mechanism.
What did it do in terms of--
Sam?
AUDIENCE: Wage for the workers?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Wage for the workers.
So you've got a price control
and a wage control provision.
Let's talk about Sutherland.
Those of you over here
must know what Sutherland--
why did Sutherland say both
of them were unconstitutional?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It says that
the mining of coal
is strictly production and it
doesn't deal with commerce.
It's just production
is local, then
there's no reason for the
federal government to--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So the
production is not commerce.
Mining the coal, making the
machine is not commerce.
And the federal government has
the power to regulate commerce.
But it doesn't have the
power to regulate production.
Unless, of course, it's
directly involved in commerce,
and what did he say about that?
Whatever the heck that means.
It's indirect, it's not direct.
OK.
What did he say about
the other provision?
Rachel?
AUDIENCE: He said that they
were independent of each other.
So that the first one
was unconstitutional,
that they could evaluate
the second one separately?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's an
interesting opinion, right?
They wrote the law.
In the law, they
said, invalidation
of any part of this
law will not affect
the validity of the others.
And Sutherland said, yeah,
I know they said that,
but they passed them both.
So clearly, they're linked.
So if one is bad, the
other's bad, goodbye.
That was interesting
reasoning, right?
That was one where you'd
say, that's not technical.
That's ideology.
That's his statement about,
I don't like that either.
And since they're
in the same bill--
you wonder, if they'd just gone
on and done the second bill--
so group A, what's Sutherland
saying about the proper role
of government?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Basically
a slippery slope.
He said, every journey
to a forbidden end
begins with a first step.
And if you're starting to
remove power from the states,
then it's easier to
next step, basically,
towards a more
powerful [INAUDIBLE]..
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
So that's a great
line, isn't it?
The slippery slope, single step.
That was one of
his better lines.
It is exactly--
"Every journey to
a forbidden end
begins with the first step."
The forbidden end.
So Sutherland's view is we got
to be very strict about what
we let the federal
government do because once it
starts expanding, we're toast.
But what's the forbidden
end that he worries about?
Where does he not want to go?
Anybody over here?
Chad?
You've made it black.
I can read it.
That's great.
We'll get you a better one soon.
AUDIENCE: So I think
that he doesn't
want like the federal government
to turn it [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
What's your
definition of tyranny?
AUDIENCE: Having
full power and doing
whatever they want without
going back to the people.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Suppose they still
had elections--
they still had elections,
but the government
had a much broader role.
Is that tyranny?
AUDIENCE: It depends.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It depends.
There's an interesting--
I'm reading this monstrously
thick biography of Hamilton.
And this was exactly the
debate over the Constitution.
And it was the debate
over Hamilton's extending
executive powers,
that it's going
to be a tyranny unless
there's a check--
unless there's a check.
You had a comment?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
To a degree, you could argue
that when the government would
begin to impose the tyranny
of the majority on a minority,
that would be when they
overstepped their bounds.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And Sutherland
wouldn't agree, would he,
that the Bill of Rights
is a sufficient check on that.
Sutherland would
say, the Constitution
says the federal government
has limited powers.
Once you go beyond
them, where do you stop?
I mean, the Bill
of Rights stops--
stops you at some
point, but there's
a lot of ground between--
yeah.
yeah?
AUDIENCE: He also
says he doesn't
like think the states should
just become main divisions.
He think it's
important that they
have their own
identity where they
can determine what happens.
So even if the
federal government
when a tyranny, wasn't taking
a toll on the people, per se,
if they undermine
the state's own laws,
then that's what
he thinks is wrong.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So he's--
he's what we now call
a Federalist, what back
in the day they
called a Republican.
He believes the
Constitution says
the states should be
strong, the states
should have a lot of power.
Maybe states could regulate
wages if they wanted to,
but the federal
government can't, OK?
So this is a limited
government point of view.
Was Sutherland right?
Team A?
Let's hear a
stirring presentation
from team A. Somebody
revved up here?
Oh come on.
Matthew, you ready to go?
Did you get yourself
psyched up over the weekend?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Based on the results
of the case, yes, he was right.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Why?
Why is that the right view
of the role of government?
You could quote
Howard Roark, right?
Howard Roark would
have liked this.
Regulate wages?
Anyway.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, they were trying to
regulate something that was not
defined in the Constitution
for that government to do,
which was the
production of the coal.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So put
aside the legal argument.
How about the philosophical
or ideological argument?
Why would you-- if you would--
agree with him absent
the legal background?
I mean, what's your
view about how--
team A-- about how society
should be organized
and about how it
should function?
Because Sutherland has a view.
Is that a view you share?
If so, why is that a good view?
I don't mean to push you.
There we go.
We'll go--
AUDIENCE: An interesting
analogy would
be that we're being recorded
here-- recorded here--
and it's, say, crossing
national lines.
And I can say
something which might
be censored in other countries.
But this law--
I know it's an analogy and
you should take it that way--
but what this law
would want to do
is censor me as opposed
to censor the broadcast.
Because they're trying to
change production, not commerce.
So what they're saying is,
let us produce what we have.
And then once it
crosses state lines,
if you want to regulate it at
that point, that's commerce.
But don't change production.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Could--
would you agree that it would
be appropriate for the state
of West Virginia to set wages
for coal mines if the
federal government can't?
Because a Sutherland person--
a good team A person would
say, yeah yeah, yeah.
There's a constitutional reason
why the feds shouldn't do it.
But I'm not happy with
the states doing it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
up to the free market
to decide what the wages
should be, not the government
to step in and do
it for the market.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you think
this is overruling
individual choice
in a way that's inappropriate?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just in my opinion,
I think in this case,
it's saying that the central
government-- or I guess,
if you want to push it
to state governments--
they're taking
over too much power
and they're basically
dictating how a person should
run their company
by saying, OK, you
have to sell it at this price.
You have to give
this amount of wages.
This is like they're setting
the guidelines and instructions
on how to run your company,
whereas in this-- where
as Coal in this
case, says, I don't
want to follow these rules.
I want to run my
company how I run.
How I want to run my company.
I have a vision of how
I want to sell coal,
how I want to make the
lifestyle for the workers here.
And if it's my company, I
should be able to do that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Is that
the right way for society
to be organized?
That's a statement about--
that's an ideological statement.
That not only is that
what he's saying,
but that's the
right thing to say
because that's the right
way to organize society.
Let me go back to
the back-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think on the philosophical
side, like you want--
if the federal
government puts a lot
of regulations on wages
and production, then you--
like Steve was just
saying, you take away
all the are entrepreneur
like opportunities
out of that situation
so that it's just kind
of filling the [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So it's a bad way
to organize society when there's
too much government because you
restrict, as Howard
Roark would say,
the entrepreneurial energies,
the creativity, et cetera.
And of course, the ability of
Carter to squeeze his workers.
Andreas?
AUDIENCE: I was going to
say, yeah, in general, he's
thinking about markets
and thinking about their--
they might not be fair, per
se, in whatever division--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Wait a
minute, you're on team A now.
Hold on here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
what I was going to say--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
AUDIENCE: You hear a word
based on the effort you put.
And until they are the
same, like as brutal as they
are to person A, they're going
to be to person B, [INAUDIBLE]
prejudice.
And like if you were--
I would trust that
markets would be
more consistent in that sense,
more fair than government.
So I think that it
makes sense for--
to have a system where you have
markets dictating the rules.
And when you have
externalities or problems,
then you might think about
state or a federal government
stepping in.
But in general, I would think
that a nicer rule to have is
look at the case where
markets do not work.
Well, then you would
have to go to, wait,
where do the markets not work,
and that's another big upset.
But what I'm saying is
that markets I think
are fair in that since.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, suppose
I told you that I knew that
all owners of coal miners
were terrible racists.
And that, in fact,
just out of prejudice,
they paid half as much to Black
workers as the white workers?
AUDIENCE: Then that would happen
is probably you would have like
another company that
would come out with--
that would pay like better
wages and could probably--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Could
hire away good Black workers
for cheap wages.
OK.
So the market does have a
tendency to be self-correcting.
So let me move on.
We'll get to the socialists
over here in a minute.
But we didn't assign
Hughes, but did you
notice Hughes said in dissent?
Hughes was a Chief Justice.
He had a-- yeah, Rory?
AUDIENCE: I think also studies.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
He just said, how can you
possibly staple these together
when the terms of the
law says they're not?
That I don't get that,
which is a pretty narrow
technical argument.
And that's why we're not
going to talk about him.
How about Cardozo?
Casey?
AUDIENCE: So he said in
regards to the price fixing
provision of the act that it was
legal because of the Commerce
Clause because the
price of coal definitely
affects interstate commerce.
And then he didn't make
a decision necessarily
with regards to the other
provision of the act that was
[INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
It's a little obscure.
Did anybody see
something that he
said that related to the
other provision as well?
He didn't say it
directly, you're right.
But he did say--
yeah, anybody?
The collectivists over here?
No.
He said-- he comes on
to this distinction
by Sutherland of direct
and indirect effects.
And he says, "The
question remains
whether it comes
within that power
is applied to interstate sales
where interstate prices are
directly or intimately affected.
Mining and agriculture
and manufacture
are not interstate
commerce, yet their relation
may be such that for the
protection of the one,
there is need to
regulate the other."
And he goes on and says that
all events direct and indirect,
even if accepted as
sufficient-- that is to say,
even if you buy Sutherland's
distinction-- must not
be read too narrowly.
In fact, I don't know how
anybody can tell the difference
or what the difference means.
I read Sutherland several times
and it made no sense to me.
But so Cardozo,
as you point out,
it's very clear that, look,
it's interstate commerce.
We can fix prices of coal
in interstate commerce
for heaven's sakes.
And then he kind of
waffles around and says,
you know, to say that wages
don't affect prices directly--
kind of odd.
You'd have to read
it kind of narrowly.
That may be the criterion--
Sutherland may
have the criterion.
But to say-- to treat directly,
narrowly is inappropriate.
So what is Cardozo's
view of the proper role?
Erica, what do you say?
What does Cardozo
think the government
should be able to do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
he says the government
should be able to
regulate it, more or less.
Where is he versus Sutherland
on, in general terms, the role
of government--
or the role of the
federal government?
Let's start there.
Rory?
AUDIENCE: He seems to be able
to do that, or should be allowed
to regulate it because given
the checks and balances
you have in the system,
while you may create a rule,
the rule can have degrees.
And so I think he talks
about the fact that--
I think he said something
along the lines of the law
isn't stupid.
It can work out when one
thing is a direct action
and one's an indirect action.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah, I
didn't get the word stupid,
but--
but, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, that's his-- that's his,
don't define them too narrowly.
A survey of the cases shows that
the words direct and indirect
have been interpreted with
suppleness of adaption
and flexibility of meaning.
The power is as broad as
the need that evokes it.
That's a nice
little phrase, too.
That kind of matches
Sutherland's journey
toward a forbidden end.
The power is as broad as
the need that evokes it.
That's a statement-- thank you
for reminding me of that lovely
phrase--
that's a statement about
the role of government.
That's a statement
about how society
should be organized, right?
What government
should be able to do.
It says, if you have a
representative government--
which is kind of assumed here--
and the government
says there is a need,
then the government can act.
I don't see a
forbidden end here.
I don't see a concern for the
sovereignty of the states.
I see a government concerned
with meeting needs.
Team B, you like that?
Why is that good?
Jackie?
AUDIENCE: I think it makes sense
for the government as the role
of the protector, especially
like during the era of the New
Deal, when it's
all about recovery,
it makes sense that
the government has more
say in what's going on than it
normally has because you can't
follow the collective decisions
of various individuals
and varying practices to
solve for something that's
a national issue.
I think that's one
of the reasons why--
like in ancient Rome, people
were willing to accept
the role of the dictator
during times of war
because they learned from Athens
democracy could be paralyzing.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So because they also--
they also accepted
emperors in times of peace
after a little while, but, hey--
but, hey.
But that's an
interesting example
of sources of legitimacy, right?
As long as the empire is growing
and people are prosperous,
do I really care that
the Praetorian Guard
put the emperor in his place, as
long as things are going well?
I'll play along.
So you think, with Cardozo,
that if a legitimately installed
government finds a real
need, the government
should be able to deal with it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think this is more
Smith's opinion, because it
doesn't necessarily
completely contradict
with what Cardozo says.
He says, particularly,
if we think
of the real policy
as supposed to deal,
or account for any externality
that the free market usually
would have considered.
And Smith says the
best representative
would be the person
who truly understands
the local population, the
climate, the geography
of that specific area.
So he what he says is there's
nothing wrong with policy,
but it's who should be the
people making that decision.
He basically-- he's against the
government making a decision
for all of the states, but he's
not necessarily against some
sort of policy for directing--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But
suppose your real concern
is terrible poverty in coal
mining areas, which was pretty
brutal, actually, in the '30s.
And you say, well, here's
what we're going to do.
We're going to let West
Virginia, a poor state,
deal with poverty
in West Virginia.
And West Virginia
doesn't have the money.
It could try to fix wages--
maybe that would be the way for
West Virginia to go forward.
But maybe not.
Maybe West Virginia
has a government
that isn't concerned with
poverty in poor areas
because it was put in
place by the coal miners.
Maybe that system broke down.
I don't know.
Rory?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] because if
I only do it in West Virginia,
then the companies
move to somewhere else.
And those prices
get forced down.
And you create a
government there,
and then only eventually do
they move back to West Virginia.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you worry about--
this is something the European
Union worries about a lot.
You worry about states--
or in the European
case, countries--
racing to the bottom,
subsidizing industries,
regulating lightly in a way that
attracts jobs, but takes them
away from somebody else
that's part of the same club.
So you say the
federal government
should be able to act
on problems like this
because you'll get competition
among the states that might
be destructive, in essence.
Anybody else from the left wing?
Yeah?
I'd
AUDIENCE: Say, because
the Depression was
like a national
problem, that you're
going to need like a national
lawmaker to bring it back up
and corporations
would cause also,
something that
affects a lot more--
prices will affect--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Lots of things.
AUDIENCE: --areas all
over and around it.
So I guess I think the federal
government should be able to--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
you would expand powers
in times of depression,
just like they
have tended historically to
be expanded in times of war,
right?
Lincoln expanded the power
of the federal government
enormously during the Civil War.
Do they get rolled back?
Once you've built the agency
and put the law in place,
do they roll back?
Jessica?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm sitting here
thinking-- because I'm
a refugee from Cuba.
So I'm definitely
not a socialist.
But when you opened with--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But
you're on team B here.
I mean, I'm sorry, we need--
we need you with--
OK.
AUDIENCE: When you opened--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Support Cardozo.
I was joking.
You don't have to be
socialist, over here.
AUDIENCE: No, it's fine.
But when you opened it,
then I was like, wow,
there are more correlations
than I realized at first.
And there's a joke that
when Castro was asking for--
when Castro was asking for an
economist, Che heard Communist.
And that's why he signed up.
So that being the opposite
sort of implication,
which is where markets
took over and they
were so bad for the people that
they just needed a government
to take over the markets.
And that's when they turned to--
let's be-- let's give
everything to this one guy.
So it might also be
a preemptive attack.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
You're talking about Cuba
before the revolution, and the
Batista government was corrupt,
was basically an
oligarchy, and gave
really nice parties in Havana
and great nightlife in Havana
for visiting Americans, and
immense poverty for much
of Cuba.
And that government
lost legitimacy.
And you got central action,
which brought a lot of literacy
to the Cuban people,
improved medical care,
and, well, better than it was.
And of course, now we're back
to grinding poverty again now
that the Soviet support
is gone, but yeah.
AUDIENCE: But the system
of checks and balances,
having that flexibility
to like open--
to give government more power
when it's needed and less when
it's not needed it might
be a preemptive strategy
to make it radical
in one direction.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Any other
defense of Cardozo's view?
The power-- let me read
that one sentence again.
The power is as broad as
the need that evokes it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: My problem
here is, one argument
lies with wages and prices, the
people who would be affected
is the general public.
And the argument is between the
market and the policymakers,
but the people who are
going to be affected
are the general public.
So let's think if we had
this debate, or we had this--
if we go back to the general
public and see what's
their opinion about this point.
So once the public--
once people would
just-- they want to
have a regular prices
and they want to
have regular wages.
They don't want like
the price to depend
on the decision of people
who own these companies
or people who run the market.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: So
most people, you think,
would in fact--
if you put this to a vote, put
the Constitution to one side--
if you put it to a
vote and you said--
and by the way,
there's another reading
that's optional that gives you
a sense of how really awful
it was to be a coal
miner in this period--
and beyond, perhaps.
If you put it to a
vote, and you said,
these people have terrible
jobs, they die young,
they're dirt poor,
things have gotten worse.
How about we pay them a living
wage and the cost of coal
goes up a little bit?
You think that would pass.
And that that
ought to be enough.
The Constitution saying,
maybe you can't do it,
maybe you can--
the fact that you could get a
vote on it, which you probably
could.
You probably could
have in the Depression.
There was a 1933 case
called Appalachian Coals,
an antitrust case that
went to the same Supreme
Court two years earlier.
And Appalachian
Coals was an attempt
by a group of coal miners--
they colluded.
They fixed the price.
They set a minimum
price of coal,
which by all the antitrust law
precedent up to that point,
was just flat illegal.
It was just no
question about it.
Go to jail-- well, yeah--
go to jail illegal.
The Supreme Court
managed to find
it legal in one of the
most bizarre opinions
you'll ever read
because it was the '30s.
It was coal miners.
These people were
in terrible shape.
So you would say, if it's
such a terrible problem,
there's clear popular
will, just do it.
Forget about the forbidden
place, forget about the states.
OK.
We got that.
Rebuttals?
Team A, you've heard
what they said.
That the power is as broad
as the need that evokes it.
You're right in the middle.
Remind me which team you're on?
OK.
You're a right-winger.
All right.
AUDIENCE: So I think that--
like so I personally probably
agree with the statement
that the coal miners were
in horrible conditions,
and by putting it to a vote,
you could probably pass it.
But I think that Sutherland's
position is, yeah, maybe that's
true.
But in many Supreme Court
cases, the basis of the decision
is what has been
said in the past.
And so if you pass-- if you
made this legal for this case,
that in future cases,
it would, like,
baby steps to the
government having
full control over everything.
So maybe like it would have
been right in that case,
but considering the
big picture, you
might be going down
a road that you
don't want to take any further.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
And the reason
you don't want to take
it is because in 1793,
the Constitution was
ratified by a bunch of guys
in breaches and powdered wigs.
AUDIENCE: And because
you don't want
to disrespect the
different corporations'
own entrepreneurial creativity.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
And the answer from this side?
We're a little unbalanced here.
We've got a lot of market
lovers not a lot of--
Rory, stand up for the
poor suffering miners.
AUDIENCE: Well, if you go back--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You've
got a forbidden place argument
there, a slippery
slope, take one step,
got to draw the line someplace,
we're going to draw it here.
AUDIENCE: From my very poor
knowledge of the Constitution,
I think it like has
clauses on eminent domain.
And you could argue that the
government of certain times
has the right to take
property from you.
And I think recently, they even
took it from private people
to give to other private people.
And the Supreme Court
said that was OK.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Things are different
now than they were in 1935.
Let me just say-- and, boy,
was that controversial.
AUDIENCE: Well, OK.
So another example
would be police laws
are pretty tyrannical
in their own way.
But they're appropriate
to the crime.
And so in the same way, you
could create tyrannical laws
in business if they're
appropriate to the crime.
And that would come from
eminent domain, which
I think is from the early '90s.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Eminent
domain is a provision--
I'm not sure it's
in the federal--
well, I think it comes
out of the common law.
It's the ability of a government
to take private property
for public purpose and
pay fair compensation--
there is a fair
compensation requirement--
which is the only way you
get power lines built,
or railroads, or
lots of other things.
You have to assemble parcels.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think-- sorry--
I'm like getting sick.
Fundamentally, there is
a trade-off between--
yeah, it's gross.
I think I'm getting
better, so I don't
think I'm contagious anymore.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Everybody now inhales.
Go ahead-- sorry.
AUDIENCE: There's always
going to be a trade-off
between freedom and equality.
And I think that like
all of this conversation
is about where do you want
to fall on that scale.
Personally-- and I think
Sutherland would agree--
that it's not OK to take
away other people's freedoms
to make them more equal.
You know, it would be nice
if in the whole world,
everyone was fine and had
the same amount of money,
and it was immaterial
because there was enough food
and everyone had equal access.
But that's not the case.
But that doesn't
mean that you get
to go around taking
away people's freedoms,
and freedoms that have been
guaranteed to them, just
to make other people better off.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: You point
to two different conceptions
of justice.
There's justice in
terms of fair outcomes
and there's justice in
terms of fair process.
And they're fundamentally
different notions.
What you're saying is, I don't
want to trample with a process
that I think is fair in
order to produce, say,
more equality than that
process would produce.
Other people might
say, well, I'm
really concerned
with inequality, say,
in the United States
today, where inequality has
been growing by any measure.
And yeah, maybe
everything's competitive
and everything's swell, but
I don't like that outcome.
So I'll fiddle
with it with taxes.
So I'm just saying there are
these two different views.
I'm not saying either
one is necessarily right.
You are more of
a process person.
You like a fair process.
And the outcome of a
fair process is fair.
Others might say, take
executive salaries.
Nobody's forcing
boards of directors
to pay high salaries--
they're very high.
Should we do something about it?
Process people say no,
outcome people say yes.
Thank you.
Other comments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think
going back to what
Rory said, while I sympathize
with the plight of the miners,
and I understand that it's
difficult to be impoverished,
especially in impoverished
states, these tyrannical laws
that TV is suggesting, are still
just a short-term solution.
And because the markets
are self-correcting
and because those participants
are voluntary, in the end,
in the long-term, maybe
after a few generations,
everything will solve itself
without these tyrannical laws
that are just inappropriate
in this situation.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Minimum
wage law is a tyrannical law.
Okey-doke.
I'm with you.
I got it.
No, no.
You just play the role.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm kind
of a right-winger
in enemy territory over here.
But I'd say, like,
I don't like really
the idea of the government
ideologically being
able to step on the toes
of private enterprise,
just the ideology of it.
But I don't know
if this is so much
an opinion on a
hindsight suggestion,
but as far as the plight
of the workers, I mean,
they have just as much
right to deny to work.
And so if you're the
federal government,
I don't know how much union
labor laws you can pass,
but I think pro-union labor
laws for coal miners, I think
would be more effective
way, if you wanted
to do it without stepping on
the toes in the Constitution
or anything like that.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
They, in fact,
moved in that direction,
the Wagner Act
and the National Labor
Relations Act I believe
came after this legislation,
which strengthened
the ability of unions.
The only thing-- since the left
wing is being very timid over
here--
the only thing I would
say is these little towns
in West Virginia, if you're a
miner and the mine goes bust,
and you own a home,
it's worthless.
So you got no job and you've
got no assets to sell to move.
Yeah, you could withhold
your labor, but I mean,
you don't have a lot of options.
It's not a frictionless--
it's not a frictionless plane.
I was involved in Washington
in the Northern Spotted Owl
debate around 1990.
And the issue there--
one of the factors
in that debate
turned on people in
small towns in Oregon
who made their living
cutting down trees.
If you regulated
logging sharply,
they had worthless homes.
And their skill was
cutting down trees.
And they got no place to go.
So unless you did something
to compensate them for that
situation-- that was a case
where it was a government
regulation, but it could
easily have been a market--
they are just stuck.
And you get alcoholism, and
child abuse, and spousal abuse,
and all of the
things that happen
when communities break down.
So it's not-- it's not pretty.
I'm trying to help
the left over here
with a little
tear-jerking argument.
But-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was going to say
just for the left-wing side,
I was going to say--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Please.
AUDIENCE: --you get
back into the argument
that electricity does
cross interstate lines.
So Congress does have the
power to regulate these laws,
regardless of how ideologically
you feel about it.
Constitutionally, it
should be allowed.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you'd say
that this whole direct/indirect
thing that Sutherland
was writing--
which he couldn't define
other than to mush around
for a couple of pages--
is really not a distinction.
That if it affects--
it affects, and there's no
direct/indirect sensible
distinction, and wages
affect prices of coal.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I'm like a fair
believer in the markets,
but I'm sitting on this
side, so I figured I'd--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Do your job.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And it was pertaining to the--
to having a fair process.
And I mean, I believe
in a fair process,
but it's always like the kind
of recursive nature in the sense
that you have to establish
a fair playground in order
for the outcome of a
fair process to be fair.
And perhaps in this case,
when shit's hitting the fan,
you really need to try and
have the government interfere
and create somewhat equality so
that the process is then fair.
And from then on, you can
then say, well, you know,
we've allowed everyone
with the same--
we've tried to give everyone
the same kind of benefits
or the same opportunities.
And from here, whoever
takes it, well,
is then a CEO and is making
money and who doesn't isn't.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And what
do the folks on this side
say in response to that?
Somebody who hasn't spoken.
Max?
AUDIENCE: I think it's a
big issue with conflict
of interest.
In this situation, you'll
have the government
that may have been trying to
act in the interest of workers,
in labor rights,
things of that nature.
But that might not
always be the case.
We've been looking
at the government
as kind of this benevolent
power that's trying
to improve workers rights.
But in the future, you'll
have all these congressmen
from different states,
and legislation passed
might not be in the
interest of one state.
It might be an interest
to another state.
And if there's a
majority, you end up
affecting one state in the
interest of many others.
And so it's where the--
if it doesn't affect interstate
commerce-- and in this case,
the argument was that
production does not
affect interstate commerce--
the federal government
shouldn't have the power
to regulate it because
of that conflict of interest.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So you think we draw
a simple, clear bright line.
There's a lot of good stuff on
the other side of that line,
but there's a lot
of bad stuff there.
Sutherland's forbidden
place is on that side.
AUDIENCE: I think
one of the comments
was the necessary evil
of an open market, where
while the government has
to accept that there are
some evils, maybe unfair labor
standards that they can't deal,
with but to have a truly
fair and open market,
you need to let those evils
exist and let the states
deal with them if they
think it's proper.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
if I were Sutherland,
I might say, look, today
it's the poor coal miners--
tomorrow, it's the poor
investment bankers.
And if we get
votes in Congress--
God knows how-- that investment
bankers' wages are too low
and they need to be
increased, and if you
let me fix a wage
for coal miners,
I'll fix a weight for
investment bankers tomorrow.
And we know that's nuts
and we need a wall.
OK.
Let me bring it to a close.
Thank you all.
This was good.
You aired a lot of
the main issues.
Let me just tell
you what happened.
After this, Roosevelt found
this string of defeats--
this was just another
defeat for the New Deal--
very frustrating.
And in 1937, he
issued a bill which
would have let him appoint
more justices to the Supreme
Court, the so-called
court-packing bill.
Two months later, the
court reversed itself
on the federal government's
ability to regulate wages.
One judge switched.
Carter versus Carter Coal
was a 5 to 4 decision.
In 1937, they switched.
This was referred to as the
switch in time that saved
nine-- nine justices
in the Supreme Court--
clever language.
The Court says, however,
they'd taken the vote earlier.
The bill died in any
case in the Senate
in July, which is why
we still have nine
justices on the Supreme Court.
Who has won historically,
Sutherland or Cardozo?
AUDIENCE: Cardozo.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Cardozo.
Do we have a federal
minimum wage?
Yes.
Scott?
AUDIENCE: I would say that's
different than this case
because the minimum wage
law isn't just for coal.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
That's true.
AUDIENCE: --coal, it
gives it every generation.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But the
fundamental question of does
the Commerce Clause stop--
that fundamental question--
stop the federal government
from regulating things
that occur inside states,
like paying wages
or setting safety
conditions for this room,
or lots of other things?
Cardozo won.
The view, at least
until recently,
was that if you could find an
impact on interstate commerce,
the federal government
could regulate it.
That's disputed now, and we
have a Supreme Court that
is tilting the other direction.
But the run of
decisions from the '30s
forward has largely been in
Cardozo's direction, at least
as regards the Commerce Clause.
But issues like this don't
get settled permanently.
The pendulum may swing.
There's a lot more concern
with states' rights, as I say.
To actually say the
federal government
should just fix
the electric system
is to get laughed out of town.
It's a state
function, full stop.
OK.
I think we've covered
what there was to cover.
Questions, comments, reactions?
Thank you.
I'll see you all tomorrow,
believe it or not.